In this video we shall review how to use custom scan configurations in BurpSuite Enterprise
Edition. In addition to the preset scan modes, you can also create and import custom configurations.
This video explains how to create and assign those custom configurations to a site.
Please note that we recommend keeping a consistent scan configuration for each site that you add.
Changing the scan configuration can affect vulnerability trends over time and cause BurpSuite
Enterprise Edition to give inaccurate time estimates while scanning. If you want to scan a site that you
have already added with a new scan configuration, we recommend adding the site again with the new
configuration selected. To assign a custom scan configuration to an existing site, select the
sites tab, select the site in question. We can then go to the details tab and select edit. If we scroll
down to the scan configuration section, we can toggle from using a preset scan mode to using a custom
configuration. This gives us access to our configuration library where we can select which
scan configuration we would like to use. This will include the built-in scan configurations as well as
any custom scan configurations that you have added. Once you've selected the scan configurations you wish to add,
you can click save. To create a custom scan configuration, navigate to settings and scan configurations.
This will display your scan configuration library. We can then select new configuration,
give the scan configuration a name and select apply. We can then toggle from the available options to create our desired scan configuration.
To learn more about what each of these options do, please see our scan configuration documentation on our website.
Additionally, we can import scan configurations both from other installations of BurpSuite Enterprise or BurpSuite Professional.
To import a scan configuration, we can select the import button and select the saved JSON from either another BurpSuite Enterprise Edition installation that has been downloaded or an export from BurpSuite Professional.
For more information on exporting configuration files from the desktop editions for Burp, please see our documentation desktop configurations page.
Thank you.